klaus barbie est normal ce pourrait être
le titre du rapport transmis au
ministère de la justice par deux
médecins et un psychologue qui ont
examiné et questionner le criminel de
guerre dans sa prison de lyon klaus
barbie et même d'une intelligence
supérieure à la moyenne conclut le
rapport
et il est en bonne forme intellectuelle
et ne se sent absolument pas coupable à
titre personnel irons-nous des actions
qu'on lui reproche au cours de l'
enquête qu'elle mène actuellement betty
du rau a rencontré des témoins qui ont
connu rencontré klaus barbie à l'époque
où il était en france et leurs
témoignages ne concordent pas forcément
avec l'idée qui est de ne donner de lui
au travers de ce rap à l'évidence dans
ce rapport klaus barbie ici est la
prison saint joseph préfère parler de sa
famille plutôt que de la période
d'occupation à lyon où il était le chef
de la quatrième section du service de
sécurité du troisième reich
il fait part aux experts de l'admiration
ressenti pour son père instituteur
relégué dans une toute petite école a eu
l'air en rhénanie peut-être parce qu'il
était un peu trop porté sur la bouteille
en tout cas tel est le sentiment d'un
camarade de classe du petit klaus
yona thanh hô tels que vous voyez là
montrer par ce crayon et que nous avons
rencontrés sur les lieux mène dans la
classe capable mais le but c'est
tendance
autre remarque de klaus barbie
il traite le président bolivien et
vibrante d'enfants naturel mal et aurait
il oublié sa propre naissance le 25
octobre 1913 ici avant le mariage de ses
parents le 30 janvier 1914
mais ce réellement important et barbie
de continuer je le cite en face de la
réalité je me concentre uniquement sur
elle et fait taire tout sentiment
réaction de simone lagrange torturé à 13
ans par barbie est confronté à ces
derniers il y a quelques mois
vous savez je suis témoin dans la sphère
de barbie j'ai des raisons d'être témoin
il m'a regardé beaucoup
barbie est parti de rire en lisant
maintenant si je regarde ma lame c'est
qu'elle est très appétissante et que ça
fait sept mois que je suis en prison que
c'est un homme
le rapport précise que klaus barbie ne
ressens ni sentiment de culpabilité ni
conflits internes
alors tant pis pour les aurès man
confronté lui aussi à klaus barbie qui a
fait déporter toute sa famille quand il
est revenu à la ramener en france
ju conflent passeur il n'y a pas si
longtemps
ce que je voudrais c'est que j'espère ce
que je souhaite c'est comme barbie un
cri de coeur qu'il manifeste que ceux
qui l' effet ils étaient obligés de le
faire parce qu'il y avait deux ordres
mais qu'ils le regrettent